الى ذلك دعا المتحدث باسم خارجيه
الامريكان الى فتح جميع المعابر الحدوديه
في سوريا من اجل وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
للمتضررين من الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه
وشدد برايس خلال مؤتمر صحفي على ضروره عدم
اعاقه المساعدات الانسانيه مشيرا الى ان
العقوبات المفروضه على نظام الاسد لا تمثل
عقبه امام وصول المساعدات
بوصول المساعدات الانسانيه دون عوائق الى
جميع انحاء سوريا وممتنون للحكومه التركيه
على تحركها لاعاده فتح المعابر الحدوديه
نرحب بانباء وصول اول قافله مساعدات من
الامم المتحده عبر معبر باب الهوى ندعو
نظام الاسد الى السماح بدخول المساعدات
عبر جميع المعابر الحدوديه على الفور
والسماح للعاملين في المجال الانساني
بالوصول الى جميع السوريين ودون استثناء
هناك العديد من العقبات التي يجب التغلب
عليها لتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه في
سوريا لكن سياسه العقوبات ليست من بينها